a female teacher has been charged with
sleeping with a 16-year-old male student
the teacher is rather young herself
she's 26 years old and she's pretty
good-looking and
so do we we I we have I guess we have to
there's only there's only one response
ever to the where were these teachers
when I was in school right that's the
that's the response that's the response
un universally one of these stories
crops up every month I don't know
probably more than that and it's some
hot young teacher and some teenage boy
usually a little bit of an older teenage
16 17 and they sleep together and the
story comes out and she gets charged
with sexual assault and then every
person in the country at least every guy
says hey nice cool man where were these
teachers when I was in school and it's
kind of a funny line I'm not denying
that it's a funny line but the fact that
that's always the
response tells you something about our
sexual ethic because it's it's
legitimately very bad it's sincerely a
bad thing and it's not just bad because
16-year-old boys shouldn't be having sex
they shouldn't be a lot of them do but
they shouldn't
be it's not just bad because this woman
is in a position of power and so there's
a a big Power imbalance here it's not
just bad because parents should be able
to send their kids to school without
worrying about their their kids being
molested by teachers
it's not ju it's not just bad because
that woman is divorced so it creates all
sorts of plants all new seeds of of
Scandal in kids Minds about that about
what marriage is about what sex is it's
not just bad because he could have
gotten her pregnant and then what would
that have led to I don't know would that
have led to an abortion I certainly hope
not would that could have derailed a lot
of this kid's life
what it's it's bad
because since the 1960s We have replaced
our old moral order with one moral Maxim
and that is if it feels good do it if it
feels good then you should do
it now if if that's our moral maximum
why should this kid not be allowed to
sleep with his teacher especially if
she's kind of young and hot and willing
well you might say because he's a minor
he's 16 oh he's 16 and he shouldn't be
allowed to have a consensual sexual
relationship with his teacher well of
course he can't a consensual sexual
relationship a 16-year-old can't consent
oh interesting cuz I was told that an
8-year-old can consent to sexual
mutilations and and puberty blockers and
hormones that will forever change his
biochemistry and weaken his bones and
sterilize him or her and probably lead
to early death so hold on an 8-year-old
can consent to that kind of permanent
radical
sexual action but a 16-year-old can't
have a fling with his young
teacher no of course that that breaks
down too
can even the the
basic moral Criterion that we accept in
Liberal modernity consent starts to
break down well no maybe look an
8-year-old can consent to that just not
this 16-year-old can consent to that
just not this it starts to break down we
all know that this story is wrong most
most sensible people know that this
story is wrong it's it's just so
scandalous it leads to a stumbling block
this is what the millstone verse of the
Bible is out whoever causes one of these
little ones to stumble the mil the fa
famous Millstone verse it's it's not
about physically harming children it's
about creating Scandal and leading
people away from
God if we all know that there's
something a little bit wrong with
this the weirdest part of the story is
that apparently the kid's father knew
and the kid's father allowed it to
happen so then the joke is oh wow father
of the year I'm going to give him number
number one dad in town mug for for
Father's day but he's not the father of
the year that's actually very bad it's
very bad to do and and we all kind of
know it deep down so what that implies
then is that our moral revolution of the
last 60 years is wrong what that implies
then is there are other moral criteria
to judge to stop making the same old
joke about this
story forces us to reconsider the entire
moral Revolution that we've had since
the 1960s
frankly this the seeds of a moral
Revolution that go back much much
further than that are
we able to to return to that are we
living in a world after virtue where we
we just can't make sense of that anymore
are is there a chance that we can
recover something of uh a sensible ethic
now I love Trump no I love the tax cuts
I love the secure borders I love no new
Wars I love the judicial appointments
and I even love his tweets I love Trump
so much that I voted for him in two
generals and even in two primaries
that's right voted for him in March 2020
when he was running un opposed so if I
could snap my fingers and make him
president for four more years I would do
it Heck if I could get 24 more years of
President Trump I would be a happy
camper but I'm voting for Vi kwami in
the primary because I am worried about
whether Trump can win yes I know he has
a support of most Republicans and I know
that he beats Biden in most head
matchups even when you consider the
swing States individually but I have a
fear that keeps me up at night and that
fear is one Willis I'm afraid that in
September when Trump is our nominee and
we have too much momentum to choose
another district attorney Willis is
going to throw Trump in a prison
jumpsuit and he will lose the support of
the most crucial voting demographic
Suburban white women I worry that they
will think a convict is a bad example
for their non-binary sons and that they
would rather have four more years of
crime inflation Mass illegal immigration
and flirtation with nuclear war my
question is are my fears based in
reality or do they present no obstacle
to voting for Donald Trump the the
founder of our Feast of CFE thank you as
always for bringing the wisdom of 1390
to
2024 marvelous question as always Arun I
don't want to discourage you from voting
for v i he's a friend of mine and I
really like the guy and I think he's had
a good candidacy so I'm not I'm not
discouraging you from doing that at all
if you want an argument as to why um
Trump's indictments are not uh a reason
to boot him off the ballot but one is
you know if if we establish that
precedent then we're just letting the
Democrats choose our nominee to me the
fact that they want to send him to St
Helena so badly is actually a mark in
his favor it makes me think that they
really are afraid of him that if he does
make it to the general that that he
really could win which I think is born
out in the polls though who knows you
know who knows there could be
Shenanigans and the polls are are not
all that
reliable uh I just also think whoever
the nominee is they're going to throw
everything at him so right now for
instance Nikki haly says that she beats
Biden by 17 points and maybe she does do
better against Biden than Trump does I
I'm a little skeptical but maybe she
does uh but she ain't going to beat him
by 17 points I promise you that it's
because the Democrats haven't attacked
her yet but the minute they start
attacking her and they're not just going
to attack her with TV ads I mean we're
now in the litigious phase of American
democracy so they're probably going to
accuse her of you know aoua or of you
know pillaging a town or of you know
High crimes and misdemeanors before she
ever gets into office
um vake same thing they'll contrive some
scandal with one of his companies or
something I don't know they'll find
something and and and when I say they
find something I mean they probably
won't actually find anything they'll
just make it up and and and use it
against him so I'm past that I I I tend
to
believe that most Americans including a
lot of Democrats think that the
indictments against Trump are wrong that
it's a political persecution even if he
is convicted uh what the Democrats
believe is that once the evidence is
presented and he's actually wearing an
orange jumpsuit that is what's going to
Rally Americans to say no this is too
much uh we can't vote for this guy I
kind of think it's the opposite though I
think that the sight of an American
president and and the most popular
candidate in the presidential race right
now in an orange jumpsuit is going to so
horrify Americans as to the Banana
Republic that we've descended into that
it will help his numbers that's that's
my guess who knows I mean we'll probably
find out but my guess that was a good
clip huh now hold up ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls YouTube
channel and we will see you next time